hello so in this lake house in upstate
New York in the Catskills Catskills
Catskills who's our friend screw you and
your face generators huh and then
charges ferociously as he decimates
everything that you meticulously stacked
on these shelves because there's 80
bitty little Kitty's kind of about them
oh honey honey no bunny no sorry keep it
all right go away saying thank you where
am I going what am i doing bran bear is
mad don't need to do that why is this
happening why why why I must dance red
god damn it why did you make a game
those even harder to control fun come to
my name come to me I'm coming to you
jack I've been misconstrued but not
really yeah that would have been weird I
reached into Wade's trunk and deep down
in the bottom there was this wet bag in
there and I pulled it out and it was
really gross because when I opened it up
it was just filled with a big sword mr.
black hey can I please
no piece of [ __ ] Oh friend maybe it was
animal pee nor that does sound like
something I do yeah it was some people
will say you can but really no if the
prairies are white there all right my
coat doesn't work though I just made it
up we'll change it if the prairies are
white they're full of shite okay there
that's the bet that's a better one okay
so white and black berries are bad but
blueberries are good yeah blueberries
you're good muffins
why muffins thanks for watching all of
the videos in this compilation are
available in the description so check
them out and if you'd like to see more
in the future please leave a like to let
me know if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more on a daily basis
please subscribe today or if you're
already subscribed share this video with
a thread thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye
you